perhaps one of the most striking aspects
about this work is part of its narrative
structure namely that Boethius
introduces philosophy to us not as a
discipline not just as a subject or even
an activity that he's engaged in but as
an interlocutor as somebody who
addresses him who speaks to him and with
whom he engages in conversation namely
as a beautiful and powerful very
brilliant woman it was quite common to
represent concepts or disciplines under
this sort of guys in antiquity and so in
a certain way what he's doing is he's
continuing a long-standing tradition
that you can find in narratives and
there's a whole story that can be told
there about why men depict the various
arts and science and their disciplines
as women but I don't want to worry too
much about that what I'm really
interested in here is the particularity
of the depiction that he is giving here
but before we think about that let's
think about what it actually means to
say that philosophy would be personified
now personification is when you take
something that we don't normally think
of in personal terms and you you
attribute to it aspects or or dimensions
that belong to a person you make it
personal what is it that a person can
actually do that an abstract concept or
an inanimate object can't do well
there's what we call agency and when
we're talking about agency we mean the
ability to actually do things to decide
things to determine upon one course or
another so the agency of animals is
rather limited the agency of human
beings is greater than animals but you
know one person may have more agency
than another
person who's in the grips of addiction
and who's being ruled by that addiction
really doesn't have that much agency a
person who is oppressed who is you know
being put into a power structure where
they really can't do very much we say
that that person lacks agency and we
talk about restoring agency to a person
or fostering agency is something that's
that's empowering and really this notion
of agency although boy feeis himself is
not going to talk about that is
something that we can we can bring to
this this work and and think about
because what she is trying to do what
philosophy is attempting to do in
exercising her own agency and acting
like a person with boëthius it is to
restore to him a kind of agency that's
been lost through the oppression of
circumstances through the prison cell
that he finds himself in through the
betrayal by other people through the
vulnerability that he's he's feeling and
through having forgotten who he really
is and what he really is so let's take a
little bit more about what it means for
a philosophy to be personal or to be
personified what's really striking about
this work is that she appears to him
having said you know I've been with you
your entire life
I haven't appeared in this sort of guys
you've been you know raised on on my
nourishment that I gave to you you have
been carrying out this long tradition
that people going all the way back to
philosophers before Socrates have been
involved in I have been with all of them
throughout this course again you know
although he's not going to speak in this
way you can see here a resemblance
between this figure of philosophy and
lady wisdom in the in the Bible in the
Proverbs opposed to lady folly and also
in the book of wisdom which is in
certain canons of the
the Bible and not in others this notion
of personification of wisdom itself
which is what philosophy is attempting
to provide philosophy is the love of
wisdom philosophy a' and philosophy is
providing wisdom to to this this guy in
the fifth and sixth century just as
she's done for over a millennium before
that so she's appearing to him and she
comes on the scene she comes to be
theists in his misery as he says when he
is bewailing his fate and saying o
things are so great before now they've
all gone to hell I mean I'm in here is
prison
maybe they're gonna kill my kids next or
my father-in-law you know being good
doesn't seem to pay you know what is
this universe that God lets these bad
things happen to good people and lets
bad people get away with with having the
good things this is a common complaint
this is not one that's totally new we
see it raised in everything from say the
book of Job to the Greek tragedies all
the way down to other works of that time
including other Christian works that
Polly theist himself would know
philosophy appears to him and what does
she do she the first thing that she does
is she says who are all these other
ladies here and those are the muses the
Greeks depicted the muses as the
personifications of things like poetry
or history and he's into poetry as it's
ironic because of course there's gonna
be tons of poetry running through this
but it's a certain kind of poetry it's
not entertainment poetry which is you
may not think of poetry as being very
entertaining these days but you know if
you want to think of entertainment
poetry now think of music lyrics we have
those for entertainment and oftentimes
they don't have any special meaning
outside of themselves she is going to
engage in poetry that's supposed to be
meaningful that's supposed to be
revealing something to then
she chases off these other these other
personified women and says look they're
not going to do you any good this is
exactly the sort of thing that they feed
upon and if you think about this if we
were in similar circumstances accused of
a crime suffering unjustly deprived of
the things that we formerly took for
granted having fallen from high down to
low under the threat of death how would
we actually spend those those days would
we watch endless Netflix we'll say we
had a computer when we scramble with the
other prisoners for getting to get a
good seat in the the TV room we'll be
sitting our cell with a TV and just
watch and watch and watch and burn the
days away trying to console ourselves in
that way try to numb ourselves would we
seek out drugs or alcohol to numb
ourselves again to not have to feel
those sort of circumstances that were in
would we would be engaged in imaginary
hopes that don't really have any
possibility of realization engaging in
fantasies so that we don't have to think
about how bad our situation is these are
things that people do will they really
produce a solution not much of one
as a matter of fact the longer that that
goes on the more of those sorts of
remedies turn out not to be remedies and
actually make a person subject to other
things they make them less able to deal
with their circumstances so she's
chasing off the muses of poetry because
they're not really going to help we
theose louie theas is like a guy who has
a very bad time and then goes to the bar
and says making you know make me a
triple not just a double but a triple
because he wants to yes we say sooth his
sorrows so we can ask of this
why is she here but we theists does ask
her right he says are you here just a
hang out with me are you here to share
my prison cell
she has grander plans for him doesn't
she she is carrying out this entire
process from book one all the way to
book five of trying to as I put here to
console him and when we think about
consoling and we think about the
consolation of philosophy what do we
really have in mind what is it to
console a person again is it just to
take them and make them no longer think
about their situation or to come up with
well you know you need to look at on the
bright side sure this person over here
who you logged is passing away and dying
perhaps a terrible death and they're
gonna be lost to you forever but you
know there is there's some good points
to it if you've got some black clothes
you'll get to wear those this sounds
very flippant doesn't it but that's you
know sort of the level of a lot of the
consolations that people produce for
these terrible situations that's not
going to solve anything is it
consolations if they're really going to
console have to do something different
so we get to the Southern Ocean and we
see that's over and over and over again
throughout the work philosophy is there
to heal blue easiest now what does that
mean that means that he is in a certain
way sick or wounded we only need healing
when something that's normally okay is
damaged is in a bad condition is
diseased needs to recover in some manner
so how can we carry out healing we have
to know what actually needs to be healed
if we're not conscious of where we're
actually damaged where were actually
wounded where we're actually hurt how
were actually hurt we can't be healed
for a philosophy
this is going to happen as she's gonna
say by recalling him she was something
that he had previously he's been
studying philosophy he's been in
conversation with her his entire life
but now when the chips are down when
he's in a really bad situation exactly
the sort of thing that philosophy ought
to be able to help him with he's
forgotten he's not only forgotten what
he's learned he's forgotten who he is
he's forgotten what he is and you know
if I hadn't put this on the board but
one of the things that we theas is going
to say about what it were are we as
human beings we are rational moral
animals this is a definition that was
used by a number of people in ancient
times and each part of that is important
we are animals we sense we have bodies
we need to nourish them we have desires
we are part of the animal kingdom as
they say but we're rational we're
different than the other animals in that
we possess the Faculty of reason that
opens up for us an entire can of worms
as well as a whole panoply of
possibilities because a rational being
can actually reflect upon its situation
and say this is awful
this is terrible I think things could be
better you know cats and dogs can be
unhappy with their their circumstances
but cats and dogs don't make big plans
for themselves that don't come to
fruition and then make them feel lousy
as a result that's only possible for a
rational animal but a rational animal
can also think out solutions to the
problems that they find themselves in
were mortal animals that means that were
subject to death and that's what he's
facing here in this prison cell he's
being held there he could be pardoned
but most likely somewhere down the line
he's going to die and he's going to die
in an unfair manner for a crime that he
didn't commit
imposed by you know testimony coming
from from people who are self-interested
imposed by a arbitrary ruler not by any
sort of judicial process this is unfair
and Yankee has to deal with it the
question is can philosophy when we get
into these sorts of personal
circumstances pan philosophy actually
provide us with consolation it can but
only if we recall what our nature
actually is if we think that we're going
to live forever in the body or that the
world somehow owes us fairness we're
going to be pretty unhappy and perhaps
the remedy for that is to look at things
in a philosophical way so that's why
she's there she tells Boethius that he
has learned all these things that she is
going to reveal to him progressively at
one point or another but he's forgotten
that and how much can we say about the
great life lessons that we ourselves
have learned at one point or another and
when we reflect upon it when we're not
in a dangerous situation when we're not
feeling upset we say oh yeah it was a
great learning experience I'm not going
to do that next time and then when we
get into the narrow passages when we get
into the the constraints of what we can
call here misery something that goes out
the door this is where it gets really
personal this is a very interesting idea
there's an interplay here between the
personal and the universal we often want
to contrast these to each other we want
to say well you know there's there's the
the abstract the universal and then
there's me there is the individual
there's the concrete human subject and
all of your stuff might be great in
theory but it doesn't work in practice
there
we often differentiate this with well
you know you got your book smarts and
then you got your street smarts or
common sense or whatever and if
philosophy really means anything
philosophy not only has to be universal
it has to be able to describe the human
condition it has to be able to describe
what's better what's worse how we ought
to behave how we should think about the
universe how we should understand
ourselves how we should understand
anything that's transcendent to us but
it also should be just as intensely
personal it ought to be able to inform
our human condition my human condition
as Greg Sandler your human condition as
whoever you are
Boethius is human condition as that poor
guy stuck in that cell after having had
an illustrious career and now about to
be killed so philosophy is saying you've
forgotten some key lessons key lessons
about things that are universal that
have to do with us all but now are being
applied in a very personal way you've
forgotten these things how are you going
to remember them how does she deal with
this does she say here's what I want you
to do I've got a book for you to read
maybe just read the first you know
introduction and the first three
chapters don't worry about the rest of
it because that's what contains the part
that you need of course not she doesn't
do that sort of thing because in a
certain way that's kind of external it's
got to be personal it's got to be part
of who one is does she say just shut up
sit back I'm gonna give you all the
answers
that's not the way philosophy works
either philosophy expects us to put
forth some effort to engage in dialogue
with her to rise to the level of the
things that we're trying to understand
instead of just demanding that they come
down to our level we and that may
require us to do some growing some
climbing some ladder making in order to
do that so that's one issue he's
forgotten things that he
actually remember there's another
problem - he's an emotional wreck
doesn't use that word and the
translation that you've got there but we
could in fact translate quite a few of
the passages with philosophy say wow you
are a hot mess boy seus what what is
going on with you all these feelings
that you're feeling again nothing wrong
with feelings but sometimes their
feelings can blind us to the way things
really are if you think about the
feelings that they get mentioned in this
this text will look at each one of these
in turn they not only can reveal the
world to us they can not only be
responses to the world or to events
sometimes even the right responses they
can also blind us to an awful lot can't
they they have a tendency to make us
close in upon ourselves and upon our
perspective and upon how we feel and to
ignore other things
Sana's why is breezy as Sam makes
perfect sense for him to be sad he's in
a prison cell he was one of the you know
top administrators he was respected he
was a great scholar he had it all
together he's what you know
very few people are able to manage
several different careers at the same
time this guy was doing it and he had a
wonderful family this is almost like you
know something that you'd see in the
lifetime or the Hallmark Channel isn't
it this guy has got it all together and
then something comes along and takes it
all away all those those wonderful gifts
of chance of fortune he's deprived of
them of course he feels sad even a
regular person who doesn't enjoy all
those sorts of things put them in a
prison cell accuse them unjustly they're
gonna be sad that's a normal human
reaction fear of course he's afraid and
that makes perfect sense as well he's
been accused of a capital crime
the king himself ordered him put in
prison there really is no appeal here
anger why is he angry because he's been
unjustly accused and not only he has he
been unjustly accused all sorts of other
people are too and he's looking at the
world as he sees it and saying this is a
screwed up place what is going on here I
thought God cared about the world why
does he let bad people get away with
doing bad things to good people and let
the bad people take the good things from
the good people and give bad things to
them instead why are things so
disordered anger is a response to them
anguish anguish is this deep pain within
one's very being a reaction to how
messed up things seem to be how hopeless
things seem to be he's really in despair
when when philosophy comes to him and
because he's feeling these emotions so
strongly that reinforces this
forgetfulness because even if he does
start to remember these things you know
what it's like when you have very strong
emotions and then you have reasonings
over here on the other side the emotions
are like loud music that drowns out the
voice over here or like the roaring of a
storm or the sea and you can't hear
what's actually being said here even
though this is what's most real this is
what's most valuable the one drowns out
the other and so she's going to have to
deal with these things she's gonna have
to remind him of what he's missing and
she's also going to have to do something
to quell these passions to lessen these
emotions that he's feeling you know he's
experiencing doubts his worldview has
fallen apart it's no longer something
that he can rely upon as he has been in
the past things literally don't make
sense anymore they seem absurd to him
and he is being you know affected by
this as a result these three things are
all reinforcing each other so what is
the remedy for that sort of thing again
can you give somebody a pill that will
make them deal with this better the way
that we give people antidepressants or
we give them you know ritalin to help
them deal with with you know problems
concentrating that won't get anyone
through this sort of thing can you just
get them a Hallmark card or the nice
pithy saying things aren't so bad could
you put a you know maybe a motivational
poster or the kitten hanging on a tree
branch or something like that those
sorts of things are so superficial they
cannot actually help us when we're in
these kind of situations when the world
has fallen apart when values no longer
seem to cohere this is a real serious
personal existential condition that
boëthius finds himself in what's most
interesting about this she talks about
progressive remedies she says well first
I'm have to deal with this then I'm
going to have to deal with this I'm
gonna give you the light remedies first
then I'm gonna give you the stronger
remedies after you're ready for them
she's like a physician who's got an
entire treatment plan in mind and is
applying it to this guy boys yes what
are her remedies some of them are
explanations I should also put here a
sort of question and answer because
she's doing that with him as well
reminders all of these sorts of things
don't you remember that this is the case
don't you see that this is connected
with this and this leads to this she
even brings in some allies she says if
Dame fortune lady fortune could show up
you know she's personifying something
herself she's introducing her own you
know let's make fortune into a person if
she could show up here's what she would
say to you which is producing a dialogue
within a dialogue it's like she's a
composer doing that but the key thing
that she's doing is introducing
arguments and when we talk about
arguments in philosophy of course we
don't mean just yelling at each other we
mean connected reasonings that are
taking place this is you
the best part of ourself the rational
part in order to make sense of things in
order to say here's how we should
understand things she's also making
distinctions she's engaging she was
philosophy engaging in philosophy doing
what philosophy does in order to
enlighten him about certain key topics
and these are key topics for the human
person I know I'm gonna be things a
little bit drawing here but I really
want to stress this that these key
topics these big picture items does God
exist
is the universe screwed why do bad
people get away with things is there a
plan to things what am i these sorts of
big questions are both Universal and
intensely personal and being able to
develop a proper understanding of those
is what is going to allow Bowie theus to
not only develop a proper viewpoint on
things in an intellectual way but to
feel alright to feel happy to enjoy the
good that he has been deprived of to
actually reconnect him with himself so
philosophy is not only personified but
shows us that philosophy as a discipline
as an activity is intensely personal
she's showing it to Bowie theus who's
then showing it to us and we're being
involved ourselves in this conversation